hey guys for those of you who want the
short summary we're launching an
investing app centered around treasuries
and bonds called Silo we've been working
on this app for the past 20 months and
we're really excited for you guys to see
it we're starting by letting friends and
family into the app and we're hoping to
start letting people off the wait list
by the end of this year if you would
like to be one of the first people to
get access to Silo please consider
joining our wait list below for those of
you who want to know more Let Me
[Music]
Explain
Silo is an investing platform that is
looking to bring the 21st century to the
underappreciated Market of bonds if
you're looking to invest in Bonds on any
existing platform whether it be Fidelity
Schwab or TD Amer trade you'll probably
be greeted with a table that looks like
this you have an assortment of maturity
dates and bond types but you don't
really get any information about who the
issuers are what other bonds they offer
or any bond specific character istics
and if you click on one of these table
entries you're taken to a page like this
where you just see a massive list of
every single Bond on the market that
fits that given category I would imagine
that this is rather overwhelming for
someone who is trying to invest in bonds
for the first time and that's why we
wanted to build an experience that
prioritizes the ease of finding and
investing in issuers that you already
know into trust for example let's say I
wanted to invest in an apple Bond I can
navigate to the search tab look up Apple
and get a list of all Apple bonds sorted
by maturity you can also sort by yield
coupon rate or our custom suitability
score for every bond in the app we use
your investment goals and profile to
create a personalized suitability score
this apple bond for example has a
suitability score of 89 and a yield to
maturity of 5.31 7% we can use a slider
here to estimate how much we would earn
on a daily monthly or annual basis at
the current yield and if we scroll down
we have all of the bond specific
characteristics speaking of bond
characteristics if you don't have a
specific issuer in mind you can navigate
over to the explore tab which by default
pulls up the five bonds that best match
your investment profile and the goals
but you can further refine the search
for example let's say I'm looking for a
corporate investment grade Bond that's
yielding at least
7.5% if I press filter I'll get a list
of bonds that meet my requirements
sorted by
suitability um let's look for an issuer
that we recognize here's one Paramount
Global it looks like this Paramount
Global bond has a yield of 7.83 6% and a
suitability score of 81 if I wanted to
invest $10,000 into this Bond I can just
use this slider and then press
earn from here I can adjust any of the
order settings I want for example let's
say I want the order to fill as quickly
as possible then I would want to switch
the order type to Market and then if I
press submit It'll ask me to authorize
using face ID and and let's give it a
second and boom the order is submitted
now if I navigate to the history tab we
can see that this order has been placed
and it looks like it's already been
filled as well so if I navigate over to
the portfolio Tab and refresh then we
can see that we have a new issuer
Paramount Global and here's all the
details about our position if I want to
sell I can do the exact same thing I can
just press sell change the order type to
Market and then I can press submit face
ID authorization and boom the order is
submitted now if I go to history you can
see the sell order it's already been
filled and if I go back to portfolio and
refresh you can see that the Paramount
position is now empty lastly you have
your profile page where you have General
housekeeping stuff like statements
settings profile and stuff like that so
that was kind of a general overview of
Silo and I hope you would agree that
it's far friendlier to use than what's
already out there but that's not why we
created Silo let me
explain the main reason that we started
developing Silo is because an entire
generation of investors are being left
behind Millennials in fact on average
Millennials tend to hold 65% of their
Assets in cash the highest of any
generation despite being the youngest
it's easy to write this off as
irresponsible Millennials who are too
busy ordering door Dash instead of
focusing on invest Ing and their
financial future but there's actually a
much darker Factor at play the 2008
financial crisis the 2008 financial
crisis affected everyone millions of
people lost their jobs their homes and
everything they ever worked for while
big Banks and irresponsible corporations
got to walk away with massive bailouts
Wells Fargo $25 billion JP Morgan Chase
$25 billion City Group another $25
billion and those are just the banks GE
walked away with a $40 billion bailout
and AIG walked away with $182 billion
bailout once again the real culprits had
walked away Scott free while it was the
everyday American that was left behind
but despite how painful this was most
Americans did work through this they
eventually got new jobs new houses and
built up new life savings everyone
except for Millennials ironically
Millennials had lost the least amount of
money given that they were all younger
adults with no money to lose but while
they didn't lose money they had lost
something much deeper a part of the
American dream they had seen their
parents and people around them lose
everything and it gave them a rather
cynical view of capitalism they felt
that there was no reason to be loyal to
a company no reason to idolize rich
people and definitely no reason to
invest given that Wall Street would just
stack the cards against them 15 years
later these fears are still very much
alive in fact a whopping 80 80% of
Millennials admit that the crisis still
influences their investing to this day
and this is largely why they tend to
hoard cash in fact nearly one in four
Millennials have Savings of $100,000 or
more yet stock market participation is
still lower than it was 23 years ago
several New Age investing companies have
tried to address this on the stock side
of things you've got people like
Robinhood weeo public.com Mumu and M1
finance and on the crypto side of things
you've got people like coinbase binance
and till recently a lot more but while
these guys have increased Market
participation I don't think they've
necessarily increased investing
participation given that these guys
aren't exactly encouraging people to
invest rather they're encouraging people
to trade stocks and options or 10x their
money with crypto and nfts much of their
pitch is trying to make investing fun
and exciting but the reality is that
investing shouldn't not be exhilarating
if it is you're probably gambling not
investing of course you'll always hear
about some random guy who made Millions
by betting on some obscure stock or
crypto but chances are you probably
won't be turning $1,000 into a million
by trading you're actually more likely
to lose the initial 1,000 why did
platform sell this Vision then you ask
well two reasons for one Untold riches
is the easiest way to get people to open
accounts and deposit money and to
Traders generate far more commissions
than Buy and Hold investors and as such
we've seen this massive gamification of
the entire investing space real
investing however isn't about making
millions overnight real investing is
about making responsible and calculated
moves to grow wealth over an entire
lifetime and this is what we would like
to bring to Market with
silo
longterm we would like to offer much
more than just bonds but we decided to
start with bonds because it's by far the
most underappreciated and underserved
asset class especially when it comes to
Everyday investors you see all of the
biggest companies and investors in the
world own hundreds of billions of
dollars worth of bonds take Apple for
instance they're currently holding $34
billion in short-term marketable
Securities and $104 billion in long-term
marketable Securities most of which is
bills and bonds similarly Microsoft is
holding $144 billion in cash cash
equivalents and short-term Investments
even Warren Buffett the legendary stock
investor is playing with a hundred
billion worth of treasury bills all of
this is only a mere fraction of the
entire bond market though the global
bond market is worth $133 trillion which
is even larger than the global stock
market which is only worth $109 trillion
but despite the raw size and ubiquity of
bonds the everyday investor has only
heard about bonds and passing so what
even are bonds well before we get into
all the technical details let's take a
step back and understand the role you
play in the bond market as individual
investors we get the unique opportunity
to help large companies and our
government raise money these
institutions really only have two main
ways they can raise money sell parts of
their company or get a loan when they
sell a part of the company you're able
to buy a piece of it through the stock
market and if you're the average
Millennial you're probably not the
biggest fan of Stock Investing because
you saw what happened in 2008 any
company could very well Crash and Burn
rendering their stock completely useless
after all didn't Amazon themselves lose
money for a decade so all of that might
sound a bit too risky and you're not
wrong investing in individual stocks can
not only be risky but unpredictable but
with that being said this risk also
comes along with a substantial amount of
upside potential if you're just looking
for a stable reliable investment that
pays out a set amount though this may be
where bonds could be of value instead of
buying a piece of the company with the
bonds you lend it to the company under a
legally binding contract and if they
don't pay you back a bunch of lawyers
would knock down their door and sell
everything they have left and pay you
back as much as possible when a company
agrees to this Arrangement they agreeing
to raise debt otherwise known as issuing
bonds and these very bonds are available
for us to purchase however they work a
bit differently than stocks for starters
the most basic characteristic of a bond
is its face value this is usually $8,000
and it's the amount of money that the
company is promising to pay you back
this doesn't mean that you'll always buy
a bond at its face value though often
times the market price of a bond will be
lower than its face value for example an
apple bond with a face value of 1,000
may be trading at 950 this means that
you only have to pay $950 to to purchase
this Bond but Apple will pay you back a
th000 when the bond matures if the
Bond's maturity is one year out you'll
earn a profit of $50 at the end of the
year which translates to roughly a 5%
yield in the meantime most bonds will
also pay out interest payments known as
coupon payments a coupon payment is a
percentage of the face value that gets
paid out usually twice a year for
example let's say that same Apple Bond
had a coupon rate of 2% in this scenario
on top of the $50 that you already
earned you would earn another $20 in the
form of coupon payments AKA your total
profit from the bond would be $70
meaning that your total yield would be
roughly 7% of course you could really
get into the weeds of this with call
dates and acud interest but in a general
sense that's how bonds work you lend a
company a bit of money they pay you some
interest for it and once the contract is
over they pay you back the full amount
and go about their business but how safe
really is all of
this
one of the biggest pros of bonds is
their consistency and reliability since
there is a legal obligation for the
lender to pay you back failure to make
these timely payments puts lenders in
default and just like how us individuals
have credit ratings that measure how
financially responsible we are companies
have credit ratings of their own that
measure the likelihood of default these
ratings are split up into two categories
investment grade and high yield or junk
investment grade is obviously the safer
of the two in fact in 14 of the past 22
years investment grade corporate bonds
did not default at all also about junk
bonds these definitely have a scary name
and we wouldn't personally recommend
these but all things considered they're
actually rather safe as well even with
all of the pressures of high inflation
and high interest rates for example as
of June the high yield Bond default rate
was still only
1.9% which just goes to to show how
seriously companies take paying back
Bond holders on Silo there's over 2,000
corporate issuers that you can choose
from but if you're really concerned
about minimizing risk your best bet
would likely be government bills and
bonds the federal government's bonds AKA
treasuries work the same way as any
other Bond however because it's the
government that's issuing them they are
seen as some of the safest Investments
available now let me preface by saying
that there is no such thing as a
risk-free investment all Investments
carry risk that's kind of why they
generate a return in the first place but
in the spectrum of risk US government
bonds are as close as you're going to
get when it comes to eliminating risk in
fact the only time that a financial
institution is allowed to describe a
return as risk-free is when they're
referring to treasury yields treasury
yields are considered risk-free because
they're backed by the US federal
government who in theory can just print
money to pay back Bond holders when it
comes to Safety and Security though the
investment itself only tells half the
story the platform through which you
invest is also equally important and
that's why we're proud to say that each
Silo account is protected by $500,000 in
sipc insurance and $2.5 million in FDIC
Insurance also all funds deposited on
the platform will be maintained by our
trusted custodian interactive brokers
who has experiened managing $373 billion
worth of assets over the past 45 years
so with Silo you're not only getting the
Sleek UI and friendly interface of a
modern investing platform but you also
get the experience and stability of an
established brokerage all of that
probably sounds nice and all but you're
probably wondering how much will all of
this
[Music]
cost when it comes to investing a key
consideration is of course cost when
Robin Hood entered the market back in
2014 they disrupted the market by
cutting commissions and fees to zero
this generated a lot of Buzz around
trading on Robin Hood however as we
found out Robin Hood still makes money
from your trades just not transparently
instead they use something called a
payment for orderflow which you could
describe as just a hidden markup that's
built into the price of the security
this is not only a frowned upon practice
but a straight up illegal one in most
countries outside of the United States
in fact the EU just banned this practice
a couple of months ago the bond market
doesn't use payment for orderflow but
Bond Brokers usually earn money in a
similar fashion through markups for
example let's say a given bond is
trading at
$950 to buy this Bond you'll probably
actually have to pay
$965 because the average bond markup is
$154 and this applies when you're
selling as well instead of being subject
to a mark up though you'll be subject to
a mark down so if a bond is trading for
$950 you may only be able to sell it for
$935 in other words for every Bond you
buy and sell you would be losing $30 to
markups and Mark Downs at Silo we wanted
to make sure that you didn't have to
worry about any of this and that's why
we have absolutely no markups or
markdowns we only have execution fees
for each order which is also passed on
at Cost how did we accomplish this you
ask well simple by aligning our interest
with yours through a subscription fee
like Costco at Costco most products are
sold with very little margin or even
negative margin and the primary way that
Costco actually makes money is through a
membership fee it's the same way with
Silo regardless of whether you buy only
one Bond per month or are investing tens
of thousands on a daily basis the price
that we get is the price that you get
the only way that we make money is
through a $10 subscription fee that is
applied to accounts that are larger than
$3,000 so as long as you buy and or sell
eight bonds per year the monthly fee
will pay for itself also if you deposit
less than $3,000 the platform is truly
just free to use whether it's the bond
prices themselves or the execution fees
everything is passed on at Cost we don't
make a dime moreover unlike other
fintech platforms we're not incentivized
to get you to trade because we make the
same amount regardless of how much you
trade so our goals are aligned to make
sure that you make investing decisions
that benefit you over the long term with
that being said we would also like to be
honest about who this platform is
actually for because it's it's not for
[Music]
everyone while we'd love for as many of
youall to use the platform as possible
we' think there is a certain group of
people who would benefit the most from
Silo after all bonds are just one asset
class and many investors would benefit
more from other Investments whether that
be stocks real estate indexes or simply
holding cash in today's environment high
yield savings accounts are yielding up
to 5 % meaning that holding cash itself
could be a great option but what about
the cash that isn't growing maybe you
have it in a Chase or Wells Fargo
account big banks are notorious for
handing out fractional interest rates on
your cash so if you're someone that's
holding cash that isn't benefiting from
the high interest rate environment or
Worse getting eaten up by high inflation
a good alternative is holding short-term
treasuries that provide rates as high as
5.5% also if you've stockpiled a bunch
of cash into a high yield savings
account one downside you should consider
is that high interest rate savings
accounts only last as long as the FED
keeps interest rates high in one two or
a few years from now decreases in
interest rates will send higho savings
rates back to the bottom so if you don't
want to play that game and just want to
lock in a rate for the next decade or
further 10 or 30-year treasuries or even
long-term corporate bonds may make sense
ironically this strategy May apply to
the other side as well for example let's
say you're heavily invested in in stocks
and are seeing that your returns over
the past year haven't been that great or
you just want to reduce volatility well
then it may be time to diversify
investing in bonds at these rates means
earning much more consistent and secure
income that has even matched stock
market performance over the past year
also what about real estate with
mortgage rates at levels past 8% it may
make more sense to earn 5% through bonds
than pay 8% on a property now a lot of
these have to do with the current
condition of our economy but one type of
investor that may benefit from Bond
investing regardless of current
conditions is a more conservative
investor who has some level of
apprehension toward stocks maybe you see
stocks as too risky unpredictable and
volatile but also feel that you should
be doing some sort of investing in this
case bonds could be the perfect middle
ground for you sure they won't have the
same return potential as stocks but it
may be a more comfortable investment as
you can see bonds can be a valuable
asset to a wide range of invest ERS but
to be honest there's a lot of people for
whom bonds are not the right choice as
[Music]
well likely the most obvious group of
people for whom Silo would not be a good
fit for is if you're not able to invest
at least $5,000 or ideally at least
$10,000 for one the monthly fee would
eat into a lot of your returns but even
putting that aside Bonds in General
probably aren't a great fit for you for
example let's say you invest $1,000 even
if you lock in a 8% yield you're only
earning $80 per year which brings up the
question of whether that's even
worthwhile it's only when you get into
tens of thousands of dollars that bond
yields really start to add up also if
you're not in a position where you can
invest $5 or $110,000 it would probably
be a better idea to build up larger cash
reserves and an emergency fund before
investing in anything someone else that
bonds may not be a good good fit for is
someone who already has a solid
investing plan in place and investing in
bonds would take away from that for
example maybe you already invest
everything you're comfortable with
investing into the S&P 500 every month
you should not start investing in bonds
if it would take away from this existing
plan in other words Bond investing
should be something that you add to your
investing strategy not something that
replaces your existing strategy bonds
would also not be a good fit for you if
you have a high risk tolerance and are
looking for high returns the truth is
that even if you're investing in the
highest yielding junk bonds you won't be
generating five or 10x returns so if
that's what you're looking for and
you're willing to take the risk stocks
and crypto would probably be a better
option also speaking of returns since
bonds pay a fixed interest rate there is
really no compounding effect when you
try to reinvest your coupon payments
there is no guarantee that bond yields
will be at the same level as when you
originally invested for example a
30-year treasury bond today yields
around 5%
but 10 years down the line if 30-year
treasuries are only yielding 3% you
wouldn't be able to reinvest the
interest payments at the same 5% yield
so if you want a single Avenue to invest
in and see your portfolio compound index
funds ETFs and mutual funds may make
more sense Silo would probably also not
be a good fit for you if you have cash
but can't afford to lock it up for a set
period of time AKA if you have a high
need for liquidity investing in bonds is
not the right choice for you rather it
would make more sense to keep your money
in a high yield savings account without
a lockin period so that you can withdraw
at any time honestly this is starting to
sound like one of those disclaimers at
the end of a medicine commercial so
let's move
on at the end of the day high inflation
and high interest rates have led us into
an environment that we haven't seen
since really the 1970s as such the value
proposition of every asset class has
drastically changed and the asset class
that likely benefited the most is fixed
income of course we're biased but we
truly believe that we have created a
stellar Bond investing platform that
redefines how retail investors are able
to invest in bonds and by choosing Silo
you would be choosing transparency ease
of use and most importantly a wide
selection of secure and consistent
Investments so if you're in the market
for something like that please consider
checking out Silo in the descript
destion below if that doesn't really
apply to you we completely understand
and appreciate you watching the entire
video anyway if you would like to learn
about how Microsoft conquered the coding
World check out this video but until
then I'm Hari and I'll see you guys on
the next
one